[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes ce soir à tunis pour
une édition spéciale consacrée à la
tunisie de ben ali
dix mois après la destitution du
président bourguiba le nouveau chef de
l'état nous a accordé une première
interview exclusive
s'il a semble-t-il apaiser la population
il n'a pas encore réussi à juguler la
crise économique chômage hausse des prix
rejoints cette année par la sécheresse
temps pertes aujourd'hui l'espoir né du
changement dans le pays le président ben
ali qui nous a reçus pierre serra et moi
à accepter tout d'abord d'expliquer les
conditions de son arrivée au pouvoir
monsieur le président bonsoir vous est
au pouvoir depuis novembre dernier vous
aviez alors estimé qu'il était
nécessaire de destituer le président
bourguiba alors qu'elle vous fait pour
la tunisie depuis
d'abord c'est pas une destitution
il s'agissait d'un acte de redressement
de salut national
vous savez avant le 7 novembre
la loi a été bafouée les institutions
paralysé et je devais bien entendu
d'établir l'état de droit et j'ai fait
ce que je dois faire c'est à dire à
répondre à l'appel du devoir et à la
tante populaire et s'était fait dans le
strict respect de la constitution et de
la loi 100 sans une goutte de sang elles
sont à moins de l'arrivée hâtive
le vrai premier service vous avez rendu
la tunisie ses danseurs de bourguiba
qu'il est au pouvoir depuis trente ans
qui était malade
j'étais malade n'était pas dans un état
de gouverner le pays n'étaient pas
gouvernés il était à vouloir arrêter à
peine à administrer
la police d'arrêter effectivement malade
et il avait un entourage néfastes
précisément lorsque vous avez été nommé
premier ministre en octobre le 12
octobre 87 est ce que le problème de la
destitution se posait déjà pour vous est
ce moment là ce avait enfin le problème
se pose et j'ai vécu avec le plus d'un
bourguiba depuis 84 et donc j'ai côtoyé
le président g le côtoyer tous les
matins de 7 heures à 10 heures j'ai vu
plus dans les bas dans quel état ils
étaient incapables et religion est là et
télévision qu'il prenait la veille
d'enquêté pas les vertébrés n'était pas
dans un état normal
celui-ci ne s'agit pas d'un coup d'état
militaire
est ce qu'on peut parler d'un coup
d'état médical il était il était seul au
volant était malade il était dans un
état de santé vraiment qui l'empêchent
de gouverner et aujourd'hui comment
va-t-il maintenant enfin quand il va
comme les vieux au moins comme quelqu'un
qui a plus de 80 ans
cana 25 ans ou les évoqué tout à l'heure
des élections sont normalement prévues
dans quelques semaines en tunisie alors
sont-elles d'abord destiné à asseoir
votre légitimité d'une part enfin
légitimité on l'a vu de fait les 7
novembre et a vu beaucoup de
manifestations ma faveur je ne sais pas
si vous avez vu que ça c'est cette
période donc légitimité gelés je l'aide
de par la constitution
ça veut dire que quand tu as les
élections présidentielles la prochaine
fois on a vu aujourd'hui que vous avez
su élaborer un pacte national avec les
partis d'opposition et a donc pas un
candidat unique à la présidence de la
république pourquoi quand as tu me vois
pas du tout c'est ouvert à toutes les
sensibilités du pays
monsieur le président vous êtes général
vous l'avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure
plusieurs de vos ministres au moins deux
sont également des officiers est ce que
cela signifie que pour la première fois
de son histoire en tunisie la l'armée de
pouvoir
écoutez la formation n'est pas
nécessairement vocation
les grands chefs d'état dans les grandes
démocraties était était bien d'origine
militaire et l'origine la chef d'état le
détail par son profil voyez juger ses
actions son programme dans cette tunisie
nouvelle dont vous avez l'ambition
vous semblez vouloir davantage intégrées
au monde arabe que tourner vers leur
apogée toujours tourné vers l'europe est
vraiment grave de panne
nous avons nous avons une vocation
maghrébine arabe ou musulmane mais mes
tyrrhénienne nous avons avec les pays du
grand maghreb
et si nous avons engagé un processus
pour l'édification d'un maghreb qui
demain maghrébine pouvait pouvait être
un instructeur valable pour la 6e qui
préfèrent fêter avec les ensembles
l'oreille un dernier problème si vous
voulez qui a un peu inquiété les pays
européens et la france notamment parce
qu'on est très sensible à ces choses là
c'est ce qu'on a pu appeler lise la
ville où l'intégrisme parfois avec abus
c'est réglé chez vous le problème ou si
vous aller calmer le jeu quand même
sauvé le tunisien sont des musulmans et
les musulmans sunnites
tolérant pas fanatique ouvert au
modernisme et avait effectivement un
problème avant
avant le 7 novembre problème du
comportement officiel vous dirai
officiel peu respectueuse des religions
donc nous avons aller certaines mesures
vont rendre à l'islam la place qui leur
revient dans un pays musulman
d'une part et d'autre part j'ai affirmé
à plusieurs reprises dans le discours
que la tunisie appartient à tous ces
enfants sans exclusive c'est peut-être
ça qui a un peu calmé les esprits
[Musique]